we have other videos that go into some
depth on the Calvin cycle and will refer
to that in this video is the normal
Calvin cycle and the focus of this video
is really a quirk that diverts us from
the normal Calvin cycle and it's a quirk
due to this enzyme right over here whose
shorthand name is Rubisco so to get a
appreciation for that quirk let's first
do a very quick overview of a normal
Calvin cycle so we can start at any
point but I'll start at the point that
is typically started to head and we can
start with this 5 carbon this 5 carbon
molecule and we're visualizing just the
carbons here for simplicity so each of
these gray circles represent a carbon
there's other atoms a part of this
molecule but we're not drawing them and
that's because the carbon accounting is
what is interesting and well not only
the Calvin cycle but also this variation
this this diversion that we're going to
see that we're going to call photo
respiration so right over here I've set
it up so that I have 6 molecules of this
we call this ribulose 1 5 Biss phosphate
because but because it's a mouthful the
shorthand notation is rubp sometimes
people might say Ruby P or I guess you
could even say rube P of some somehow
but each of these six rube P or rubp s
can then react with a carbon dioxide so
for if I have six if I have six rubp s
well they're going to react with six
carbon dioxides
and so one way to think about it is it's
fixing the carbon in that carbon dioxide
it's taking this carbon that's part of
the this gaseous carbon dioxide and
fixing it as part of an organic molecule
now you might be tempted to say well is
going to create six six carbon molecules
but then those will immediately become
12 three carbon molecules and notice and
it's important to keep doing this pause
the video if you need to you can make
sure that the the carbons are all
accounted for right over here how many
carbons do we have well we have six
times five so that's 30 carbons right
over here and here we have six times one
carbon so that's six carbons right over
here so if we want to account for all of
our carbons we should have 36 carbons
over here and we do we have 12 3 carbon
molecules this three carbon molecules
when we go into into some into some
detail here in the video on the Calvin
cycle it's called 3 phosphoglycerate but
that's not what the focus is on this
video the focus of this video is the
enzyme that actually does the the fixing
of the carbon along with the rubp
and that enzyme that character the
character with the quirks that we're
going to talk about the shorthand it's
name you could call it ribulose 1/5 this
phosphate oxygenase carboxylase but
that's even more of a mouthful than rubp
so people call it the nice friendly name
Rubisco Rubisco for short but you could
learn a lot about about what Rubisco
does from its name right over here and
you can even learn a little bit about
its quirk that we're about to talk about
so it obviously involves ribulose 1/5
this phosphate and it does indeed
involve that and then you see oxygenase
- carboxylase
well the carboxylase is what tells us
that it will it can deal with the carbon
dioxide right over here that carbon
dioxide can be one of the substrates in
a reaction with the robbie buhl owes 1/5
this phosphate and so that's exactly
what it's doing in this reaction in a
normal calvin cycle it's acting as a
carboxylate it is fixing that carbon
it's making it part of if you view you
know if you view that carbon actually I
won't do it that way because here we
have 12 as many but it's taking these
carbon molecules and it's fixing them
into organic molecules some of which can
eventually be used to create glucose and
that's what happens in a typical calvin
cycle we use up some NADPH --is we use
up some ATP's and we go down we through
this cycle eventually we create some
g3ps which are also three carbon
molecules g3p is short for
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate for those of
you who are interested and then if we
use this accounting of those 12 10
go back through the Calvin cycle to
regenerate our ribulose 1/5 bisphosphate
and two of them exit the Calvin cycle
and then can be used to produce one six
carbon glucose and so that's what
happens when everything is fine and
dandy that's what the Calvin cycles
purpose is is to be able to have a store
of energy in the form of glucose now you
might have already got gotten a little
bit of the foreshadowing from Rubisco x'
name well maybe it sometimes acts as an
oxygen ace so instead of fixing carbon
maybe sometimes it fixes oxygen and that
is indeed the quirk that I'm talking
about of Rubisco so in photorespiration
instead of fixing carbon it fixes oxygen
along with the ribulose 1/5 this
phosphate and you might say why does it
do that and the answer is well that's a
really good question some folks think
well that's just one of these
inefficiencies of a biological process
it really shouldn't do it it's a it's in
some ways detrimental to the plant it's
it could be a side effect a legacy
feature or side effect from ancient
ancient evolution when there was very
little oxygen in the atmosphere and so
this didn't seem like that bad of an
inefficiency but it does happen and in
particular the times where
photorespiration is more likely to
happen with typical plants often
referred to as c3 plants and c3 it's
referred to because the first product
when you fix the carbon is a three
carbon molecule
but this typically happens or this
happens with typical plants in hotter
than normal weather so let me write this
down I'll write it in a hot color hot
hot conditions that's where it typically
happens with typical with typical plants
and why hot conditions well in hot
conditions
first of all Rubisco is just more has
more affinity Rubisco x' Rubisco x'
affinity affinity 202 increases so under
normal conditions
it tends to have more affinity for
carbon dioxide but under hot conditions
these proteins are no protein is perfect
it can morph a little bit so it has more
affinity to molecular oxygen and also
under hot conditions under hot
conditions plants are worried about
conserving water and so they will close
their stomata stomata stomata closed to
preserve water but when the stomata are
closed you have co2 can't diffuse in
can't diffuse in and Oh - can't diffuse
out can't diffuse diffuse out so your
ratio of o2 - co2 increases so Oh - to
co2 ratio ratio increases so under hot
weather the Rubisco just wants to work
with the oxygen more it typically wants
to work with the carbon dioxide and also
because the stomata is closed and you
don't have as easy diffusion well this
ratio is going to increase and so things
are just more likely to react with the
oxygen especially the Rubisco is more
likely to bump into it in the right way
than it is with the carbon dioxide but
let's think a little bit about why this
this is inefficient well in this case
it's fixing the it's it's fixing the
oxygen and so it's not gaining those
carbons like we just saw in the typical
or the normal Calvin cycle and so here
and you can you can account Paul I
encourage you to keep pausing the video
and account for the carbons but here and
you can't you can no longer produce you
can no longer produce your 12 3 carbon
molecules because you're not getting
these 6 carbons over here so instead you
can only produce six of those 3 carbon
molecules and then another six of the
two a two carbon molecule called phospho
glycolate and once again I'm not showing
all the oxygens and I'm not showing all
the phosphates I'm just accounting for
the carbons and so this seems like a
pretty bad loss you're not able to use
those car
right over there well evolution has
given us pathways to at least start to
salvage some of it but it's a pretty
it's a pretty intense pathway to get
back some of those carbons and the
reason why it wants to get back some of
those carbons is because remember at the
end of the day you want to you want to
attempt to produce some glucose and you
want to have the typical or the normal
Calvin cycle continue to happen but just
so you get a sense of what the salvage
pathway looks like that phosphorus to
carbon this two carbon molecule right
over here it has to be converted to
glycolate then that has to go to the
peroxisomes where it becomes glycine to
the mitochondria you see this whole
process here just to be able to salvage
it into a few more of the three carbon
molecules and that's essentially what
happens right over here we get three
more of the three carbon molecules but
we do lose four the way I have accounted
of it
three molecules of carbon dioxide and
this is one way that why it's called or
one reasoning for why it's called photo
respiration respiration we use oxygen
and we produce carbon dioxide and that's
exactly what's happening we're using
oxygen and we're producing carbon
dioxide and so as you see this is the
mechanism it kind of makes the calvin
cycle it disrupts it or it makes it less
efficient and so once again why does
this happen well it could just be a
biological quirk that has not been
selected strongly enough against or some
people believe it actually has some not
so well understood mechanism and it
somehow helps the plant in some way but
it's a really interesting thing that
goes on and you know Rubisco is not just
some very fringe molecule as you see
it's central to the calvin cycle and if
you look at plant matter in particular
plant leaves it'll represent roughly
twenty percent of the protein mass in
those plant leaves so it's a very common
it's a very common a protein slash
enzyme but it's got this quirk this
quirk that takes the plant down the path
of photorespiration